10 Editing Mistakes In Popular Superhero Movies
That Went Unnoticed
Mistakes happen in any line of work.
We live with them, we move on.
The world of movies is no different.
The editing process is susceptible to errors
just like any other.
Unfortunately for the people behind these
errors, the evidence is permanently etched
into movie history once the movie in question
is released.
That's not to say it's an unforgivably bad
thing, or something we should complain about
relentlessly... it's just... well, it's just
a thing!
If anything, it gives us something to look
out for and talk about!
So that's what we're going to do here!
Enjoy the video and subscribe to our channel
for more of the same.
Here are ten editing mistakes in popular superhero
movies that went unnoticed.
The Avengers
Let's start with a funny one.
In 2012's The Avengers, the final battle sees
the titular team of superheroes taking on
the Chitauri army led by Loki in New York
City - and it's a scene involving the God
of Mischief that we're talking about here.
When Tom Hiddleston's character catches an
arrow fired at him by Hawkeye, his other hand
is supposed to be resting on the handle of
the Chitauri flyer he's riding on.
However, the movie's special effects team
failed to actually add the handle, so Loki's
hand is actually resting on nothing.
Superman Returns
2006's Superman Returns really wasn't very
good.
It wasn't awful, but hardly anything truly
exciting happened!
That being said, the one truly exciting scene
was the one we're including here because of
an editing mistake it contained.
It's the scene in which Superman stops the
aeroplane from crashing into the baseball
field.
After he's safely put the plane on the field,
there's a wide shot in which Superman, the
plane and baseball players can all be seen
- all of which cast shadows onto the pitch
except Superman himself.
Captain America: Civil War
At the end of 2016's Captain America: Civil
War, Helmut Zemo, Tony Stark, Steve Rogers,
Bucky Barnes and T'Challa end up at a HYDRA
base in Siberia.
Most of the action takes place inside the
base itself, but there is a scene outside
- and it's when Zemo and T'Challa interact.
Siberia's freezing, right?
So it's pretty strange that nobody's breath
is visible.
Clearly the scene wasn't filmed in a freezing
location, but you would think that the breath
would have been edited in for the purpose
of authenticity.
The Amazing Spider-Man
2012's The Amazing Spider-Man was actually
teaming with editing mistakes, but none were
more noticeable - or, frankly, more hilarious
- than this one.
In the scene on the subway when Peter Parker
has just acquired his powers and is unable
to control them, he inadvertently gets into
a fight with a number of his fellow passengers.
One of them - a black man - uses Parker's
own skateboard as a weapon but, out of nowhere,
he changes into a white guy wearing totally
different clothes!
That's some pretty poor scene-chopping right
there!
Doctor Strange
In 2016's Doctor Strange, Benedict Cumberbatch's
titular character is involved in a terrible
car crash that wrecks his body, including
his all-important fingers, which ruins his
career as a surgeon, prompting him to go on
a journey that leads to him becoming a sorcerer.
When he's training with Karl Mordo, after
he gets knocked down, you can briefly see
Strange's fingers.
In the shot in question, his fingers are in
perfect condition and appear unharmed.
However, at this point, he is still badly
maimed and you see this again afterwards.
Deadpool
2016's Deadpool was so much fun that, frankly,
it could have made some huge editing errors
and we'd have been happy to let it get away
with them.
This one was only small, however, but it's
notable enough to point out.
In the scene in which Colossus is sent flying
by a punch from Angel Dust, everyone in the
background - apart from Deadpool, that is
- appears to be frozen in time, with one of
them even frozen whilst in the middle of a
stepping motion.
X-Men: Apocalypse
Here's one for the video game geeks out there.
X-Men: Apocalypse wasn't great.
The 2016 installment in the X-Men movie franchise
received some of the worst reviews since the
series began back in 2000 - and careless errors
like this one won't have helped its cause
one bit!
When Evan Peters' Quicksilver is playing Ms.
Pac-Man at home, the titular character he's
controlling dies.
However, the sound effect is that of the original
Pac-Man dying, and not Ms. Pac-Man at all.
Guardians of the Galaxy
Guardians of the Galaxy was so good that it
seems like a huge shame to pick fault with
any of the 2014 space epic!
This happened, however, so we're going to
talk about it!
On the Nova Corps planet of Xandar, when Gamora
is trying to get her hands on the Orb Infinity
Stone, she jumps down from a walkway to the
level below.
She clearly lands with both feet close to
each other, but when the camera quickly cuts
further away, she's practically doing
the splits.
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
Oh Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice, how
you disappointed us!
The 2016 offering just didn't live up to expectations
- and there were also a number of editing
errors in the movie.
A couple of those occurred in the scene in
which Wonder Woman is looking at the email
sent to her by Bruce Wayne.
First of all, the total size of the email's
content is shown to be 24 megabytes, but when
you see the sizes of the four individual files
it contains, it should be closer to 800 megabytes.
Moreover, when Diana slides her finger to
the left on the touchpad, the cursor actually
moves to the right.
Suicide Squad
In 2016's Suicide Squad, one of the titular
team's surprise big-guns was Diablo, who was
played by Jay Hernandez.
Diablo had a huge fiery form that he used
to take on Incubus in the movie's final battle,
but just prior to that happening, there was
an editing error.
Diablo had just been knocked away by the villain,
and the scythe tattoo on his forehead appeared
to switch from facing his right to his left,
which means that the image was mirrored for
some reason.
Thanks for watching our video about ten editing
mistakes in popular superhero movies that
went unnoticed.
Can you think of any other editing mistakes
from superhero movies?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.